this guy you are the king of uh clip
shows yeah who would have thought
a man who would have thought you could
get created a a legacy of clip show but
here's the thing i didn't realize until
the walk over here
rob has an amazing
life philosophy
as far as how you compartmentalize your
work he i said to him this well this is
great first of all in the greeting he
went i'm living the [ __ ] dream so
here's a guy that appreciates it and
doesn't take it for granted you want to
tell me the philosophy that you have
well look you know number one i live an
extraordinary life um let me but but on
all levels right and it's because i have
complete harmony in all the systems that
integrate in my life right because your
life is basically made up of all these
systems
and i have essentially mastered time
energy and capacity right
and so part of that is really designing
the life that you want to live and
growing into becoming the ideal version
of yourself
and that's really what i've done now
television is what people would most
mainly know me for from the mainstream
point of view but it's a side hustle
um and i do shoot 250 episodes a year i
did build and sell a production company
uh for a significant amount of money as
part of you know my true passion which
is building
and selling businesses where i've built
and sold
uh since 2016 19 businesses sold six of
them right it's my true passion wait
you've built 19 businesses that's
correct what are the different
businesses uh i have a plant-based snack
food company called outstanding foods
that does a pigless pork rind i have a
food
look you would love the piglets pork
rind it's called pig out with bay the
pig you would love it mind right
nootropic superfood luso cloud comfort
footwear blackfeather whiskey are those
your own no that's a nike
this is a nike presto this is that a
collab no just for fun but you have your
own shoe company yeah where are you
no no i'm just in the middle of building
that it's our it's our beauty looked at
the marketplace the three and a half
billion dollars in market sales between
clarks
um or between uggs
uh crocs and birkenstock and said hey i
could make a
nicer luxury version that's just as ugly
and i built luke lusso cloud that's one
of the big ones that we've seen you've
sold how many companies sold six a
little over 500 million since we
launched uh in 2016.
and and the idea is i built a system to
curate ideas individuals and build it
into profitable sustainable acquirable
businesses that's what i do most of my
time
again i track everything i do every
single day and you study business i did
not i quit high school at 16 years old
you know
and i had to learn this the hard way i
learned this by losing millions of
dollars in trial and error of building
mini companies but apparently you had
millions to lose so i did
man i tell you what i did you grew up
with money i did not i i grew up with
nothing and where are you from from
dayton ohio right you know but i was
raised by entrepreneur wolves right i
the the young kids that i hung out with
had started companies in their team in
their teen years so skateboarding wasn't
your first thing
it was it was skateboarding was my first
outlet because i befriended a serial
entrepreneur who owned the local skate
shop then i started being around pros
and other things and got really good and
then i turned pro and quit high school
at 16. but i digress okay and where i
track every bit of time in my day and i
live this beautiful balanced life where
i spend you know 30 sleeping 10 on my
health 30 with my wife and kids and
friends right then i work 30
and so when you're managing your
capacity you have two options you
uh either hire somebody do less or you
automate it so i built this incredible
highly automated existence that allows
me to do a significant amount of things
with least amount of effort right and
that's where i've automated
ridiculousness in a way
to to produce and shoot 250 episodes a
year it takes four percent of my total
time right wait 250 episodes takes four
percent that's right
that's right and that's probably the
thing that people know you at least in
america know you most for well i would
say it's what people mostly know me for
period just because you know you it's 60
70 of the entire network i've been on
the network for 15 years have you been
asked to be on shark tank because you
seem like the uh you know
the mark cuban of the
younger generation they've dabbled with
the all those different you know they
try to get me on all the different
different sort of things but again i'm
not like a tv host they try to get me to
host network shows and different things
i did shoot a business pilot for uh nbc
that was going to be one of my
uh bigger sort of integrated marketing
like hero stories but the pilot didn't
get picked up it didn't have the heart
of shark tank
it was i was too focused on making the
brilliant back-end business side of it
uh but yeah i'm i to me it's still
you've been talking to me for what three
minutes now yeah yeah and i am so bold
over by you are not who i thought you
were yeah um and and you are so much
more than i thought i also saw i noticed
that you have a business where you're
looking for entrepreneurs kind of like
shark tank right where you facilitate
their business ideas and help them grow
yeah like on my podcast i have people
that pitch me business ideas and i give
them advice in both life strategy and
business strategy but my
you know i call it the my venture studio
it's a venture creation studio where i
only build businesses from the idea
stage so i let people pitch me ideas
um because that's where i like to create
let's make the name let's build the
business i got an idea what do you got
can you lend me 11 bucks i could lend
you
every bit of money i have only i don't
have a wallet on me i don't have a
wallet on me
[Music]
you